كان شعورك لما اجاكي الخبر والتليفون بانه
هو موجود وعم بدور عليك وبده يشوفك
السلام عليكم انا كنت كنت دايما بتصل بيه
باهله
كنت على طول بسال عليه بتصل بالتليفون ما
حدش بيرضى يديني ويقولوا لي لا احنا قلنا
له ان انت متي فما كانش ما كانش يعني ما
كانش ينفع ان انا اكلمه يقولوا لي لا ما
ينفعش احنا قلنا له ان انت متي فانا ما
ينفعش ان انت تكلميه
فكنت دايما اقول لهم
طب اسمع صوتهم مش هقول لهم ان انا مش هقول
له ان انا امه بس اسمع صوته
كان برضو في رفض منهم
فعشان كنت عاوزه اروح السفاره بس ادام هم
رافضين ما ينفعش ان انا اروح السفاره
طيب يعني لما شفتيه انا انا ابي هذا هذا
الواقع لما شفتيه اول مره بعد ثلاثين سنه
ثلاثه عقود وانت وهو بعيد عنك ايه المشاعر
كيف عرفتي اول شيء عرفت ازاي
انا ما كنتش مصدقه في الاول ان هو قالوا
لي ان ابنك ابنك جه وتدور عليك ولاقيكي
فما كنتش مصدقه اكننا في حلم يعني شعور
فرحه مع ان انا مش مصدقه ده فعلا حقيقه
يعني ده انا مش دي حقيقه اللي بتحصل دي مش
مصدقه
طيب احنا الدموع الصادقه اكيد مقدرينها
احنا
عن جد
يعني حسين
معك برامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات